what did the performing arts school
teach you about acting that still stays
with you today that's not just about
technique but that's about the business
of it um my first acting teacher I'll
never forget her name was Helen Harris
and she always got on me about getting
into the characters they should be very
shy so I'd get on stage and I'd read the
lines and I just was kind of off and
then you know and she stopped and she
was with teachers that were just yelling
yeah oh she was like what are you doing
and I remember that whatever script it
was I was playing someone in the army
and I was coming home and seeing my wife
for the first time in a long time she
was like you're in the army stand up
straight speak loud we direct be firm
get into like we should we just go and
go in on me and so she's stuck with me
because it's like that's part of the
reason now if I get a role I like to try
to attack it you know like get into the
character I'm not the same shy kid I was
back then
so now I take that with me and really
dive into a role what changed the
shyness age maturity life changed the
the shyness okay so your advice for a
shy actor advice for shy actor get into
some classes and get used to performing
in front of and with people and get
training then open you up what if
someone has a social phobia the same
thing you have a social phobia get into
classes get some training and that a
good teacher and also the people around
you help you open up
you